sur le domaine de dôme et nate cette
vendange est plus qu'une récolte
classique c'est une renaissance car
installé depuis 2013 ces vignerons
failli tout perdre par manque d'argent
il n'avait plus de liquidités
financières pour meutre intègre 20 et
aucune groupe ne voulait les aider
c'était pas un gros coup c'était 3000
euros mais les banques n'étaient pas
intéressés par notre exploitation parce
qu'on n'avait pas assez de garanties
nous allions du vin en cuve mais pour
eux la garantie n'était pas là donc ils
n'avions pas de quoi financer notre mise
en bouteille et c'est dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire qu'ils trouveront
leur salut car la somme de 3000 euros a
pu leur être prêté à taux zéro par une
association canio de solidaires c'est
son nom elle permet d'aider des porteurs
de projets
les critères c'est d'abord de
l'agriculture biologique et le principe
de proximité le dire voilà ce que l'on
veut c'est recréer du lien social
recueille de la solidarité donc nouveau
typiquement s'engage sur des projets qui
ont un 30 km autour de notre de tournus
points le principe est simple chaque
adhérent de l'association donne un peu
d'argent mais pas que l'esprit c'est
aussi de développer un réseau
j'ai connu des gens autour qui nous ont
soutenus et qui aujourd'hui vendanges
avec nous gracieusement et c'est génial
parce que nous on a pu se lancer dans
notre production de vin fournir nos
étiquettes nos bouteilles nos bouchons
et ça nous a permis de nous lancer de
partir à l'aventuré et avec près de 4000
bouteilles commercialisées le tout sans
pesticides
l'activité du domaine démarre tout
doucement mais sûrement